what is up everybody it's 414 anime here
for anime or prom and today we're going
to be ranking every captain from weakest
to strongest similar to our recent video
where we covered all of the captain's
Powers link to that in the video
description by the way we again have a
lot of captains to break down as we are
looking at the current captains and the
former ones too so buckle up as we have
a lot to get through now if you do enjoy
these bleach videos on the channel and
you'd like to see more you know what to
do smash that like button get Suga
tensho style if you haven't already make
this the video that you subscribe and
hit that notification Bell to turn on
all notifications you can also follow us
on Twitter and Instagram at anime
overall and now without further Ado
let's jump into It spoilers and all
coming in at the bottom of this list is
Lisa now to become a Captain is no small
fee so I have to mention here that
though she is at the bottom of this list
it does not mean that she isn't strong
every single member on this list is a
master in swordsmanship keto shumpo and
more they possess an insane amount of
spiritual pressure as well as immense
strength durability and endurance not
only do they have raw power but they
have very high tactical and strategic
intellect Lisa Rose through the ranks as
the once Lieutenant of shunsui to become
the captain of the eighth division she
has an expert Mastery of her zompoc toe
being able to wield it with both her
left and right hand to which she
frequently swaps between during combat
we saw just how skilled she was with the
sword when she used her move send Maya
roshi against a menos Grande defeating
it with absolute ease she also has her
qualification Powers which give all her
Shinigami Powers a significant boost
however she can only hold her
holification for five minutes at a time
now because of this and the fact that we
have only really seen her in fights that
she has either been interrupted or she
is unfortunately taken the L she has to
be placed here compared to the other
captains on the list but like I said
this does not mean that our girl is not
strong
next up is another of the wizard
captains in love ikawa the former
captain of the seventh division love is
an absolute Powerhouse we have seen his
crazy strength on hand and I mean
literally so we saw him take down
several high-leveled Hollows at the same
time one of which was him putting his
hands straight through the mask of a
Manos Grande and then completely
splitting it in two as if it was nothing
now here's arguably one of the most
laid-back captains on the list but this
shouldn't be used as a pointer
underestimate him as he is very skilled
and has a ton of experience behind him
not only that but he is a master
strategist and has been able to swing
the outcome of a battle in his favor
many many a time of course just like as
we mentioned with Lisa love gets a very
significant boost in power when he takes
on his holification however he can only
sustain him is for three minutes at a
time though it is less than Lisa I do
believe that in a one-on-one fight
Love's power would give him the win
against her thus placing him above her
again we haven't seen him win against
any major opponents his most noticeable
battle was against Stark to which he and
Rose survived but it was ultimately
shunsui who got the final blow we also
saw him go up against Eisen a little
later but he was just not a match for
him at all
now I know this guy was only an anime
only filler character but he was still a
captain shusuke armagai was the former
third division captain and one that had
so much potential from what we saw of
I'm a guy he was just you know super
impressive he had a way of leading and
rallying those around him not only that
but he also had the power to back it up
his zombogto was a fire type that packed
a lot of strength to it and also is
worth mentioning here that he is the
first captain in today's list that
possesses bunkai so we saw in his fight
against Ichigo just how strong and
experienced he was as a fighter he had
masterful control over his zompoc toe
and was certainly a Powerhouse but he
also had another weapon up his sleeve
that weapon was of course his bacoto now
the special ability of his picoto was
that it could completely negate a soul
Reaper from their soul Reaper Powers by
cutting the connection between them and
their spiritual energy thus meaning that
their zompoc toe became completely
useless to them in a fight yes our boy
was an anime only but he was one that I
truly loved watching and a character
that I constantly wondered you know but
what if you were a main captain in the
show you know just how much could you
have brought to the table unfortunately
we will never know and for that fact we
will place armor guy just here
now we were talking of Love's battle
against Stark and how he fought
alongside Rose so here he is on the list
Rose is among a select few who were
stripped of their powers and Captain's
status but were later reinstated after
eisen's defeat Rose being the current
captain of the third division which is a
very clear nod to us that his abilities
are up there with the best Rose has
mustered his Bankai which again speaks
volumes of his power and experience his
Bankai is one that allows him to create
visual Illusions using music which is a
very nasty one to go up against he also
has hollification as advised which will
give his powers a huge boost however
just as love Rose can only maintain his
Hollow mask for three minutes at a time
now we have seen him like the previous
two visor captains make quick work of
some very high High leveled Hollows
which you know is impressive again he
did fight alongside love against Stark
but the two were clearly unmatched and
for the start of the battle he was
pretty much just a bystander until he
was crushed by some rubble from another
battle he did join in on the fight and
survived but the two certainly struggled
especially against Stark's wolves now we
really got to see what he was made of in
his battle against mask we saw just how
impressive his bonkite is where we saw
him use both his sea drift and
Prometheus abilities but before we could
see the big boy Power move mask burst
his own eardrums which made Rose's
bonkai pretty useless and he was then
hit by mask star flash attack before
being saved by renji so although Rose
took the L in his most noticeable fight
the demonstration of his powers and
Bankai were more than to solidify his
place above the previous two visor
captains
Henry kuchki is next up he was the
former captain of the sixth division
over
110 years ago and though there is a lot
about him we don't really know when it
comes to power I feel there is enough
information that gives him a deserved
place on this list so first of all we
know that he was the 27th head of the
noble kuchki family and with that
position we can presume that it comes
with a person who is both wise and
Powerful also the fact that he is
biogria's Grandfather would further Aid
in our assumptions of his strength it
must also be noted that he was present
at the promotion ceremony of the newly
promoted 12th division Captain kisuke
urahara alongside head captain Yamamoto
and Captain unahana both who are
extremely strong captains now we know
that one of his greatest strengths was
that of his intellect where he would
very quickly be able to determine his
opponent's strengths and weaknesses and
then use that knowledge to put together
a counter-attack as well as that ginray
had a great amount of spiritual energy
that could repel even the most powerful
of hypnotic spells and was a very very
skilled swordsman and though this
knowledge of him is little and we never
really got to see him in battle it is
clear from his lineage and importance
the ginray was certainly a force not to
be underestimated
kensei mukaruma is another Visage on our
list who was stripped of his captaincy
later to have it reinstated post eisen's
defeat kensei is certainly a very very
powerful Shinigami whose brute power and
strength is most noticeably seen when it
comes to close combat we saw him knock
Ichigo back a great distance with just
one elbow strike and in the fake
karakura Town Arc we also saw kensei
dispatch multiple high-leveled Hollows
with just his fists now physical
hand-to-hand combat is really where
kensei shines but it's not all brute
strength when it comes to his power but
it's his ability to be perceptive while
on the battlefield that has often given
him the upper hand against his opponent
now kensei does prefer his hand-to-hand
combat style but what makes him
extremely impressive is the fact that he
combines this style of fighting with his
swordsman's skills using the two in
Union his shikai and bonkai are both
very impressive too he manipulates the
wind utilizing wind slashes and
explosions to completely overwhelm his
enemy his bunkai simply puts this
destructive power into two knuckle
blades that pack a punch excuse the pun
and as advised he of course has the same
qualification Powers as the others which
not only boost his Shinigami Powers
significantly but also his punches
gained more power as his fists are
covered in spiritual energy kensei can
maintain his Hollow mask for five
minutes at a time so I believe of the
Visage we have covered thus far kensei
definitely stands above the others as
his strength is just insane he managed
to block Wonder wise's attack and then
hurled him a great distance with just
one hand before holifying and we also
saw a good display of his power against
mask with said knowledge on this guy he
had to take this spot on the list
Conor May tozen takes the next spot and
I guess you could argue is the first OG
captain on today's list he was the
former captain of the ninth division
prior to his portrayal of the Soul
Society alongside Guin ichimaru and
sosuke Eisen now kaname's powers are
interesting pre-holification his powers
are all about manipulating his
opponent's senses his shikai has the
power to completely overwhelm his
opponent's hearing to the point of them
losing Consciousness and his bonkai
creates a space that takes away all of
his opponents senses bar Touch of course
it is that sense of touch that is the
downside to his bonkai as its greatest
weakness is the fact that it has touch
nullification we saw this in koname's
fight against the brute strength of
kempachi's Iraqi yes kaname's bunkai is
an extremely powerful one but that one
slight opening completely changed the
game in that fight now when it comes to
kaname he has both hollification and a
resurrection that make him an absolute
lethal threat particularly in the fight
against both komamura and his Sagi
kaname was utilizing all of the
holification abilities at his disposal
which include the power enhancement and
the very high speed regeneration kaname
was able to go up against komamura's
bonkai Toe to Toe while holified but
took the fight to the next level when he
Unleashed his resurrection turning
himself into a horrid insect-like
creature in this form koname was able to
block and Crush komamora's bonkai's
sword and also crack his chest causing a
mirrored injury to komamora himself
economy was certainly a very strong
character now if we were to base it off
of just his Shinigami power is I think
he would have been a little bit further
down the list while they are very
impressive they also have their
drawbacks but when you add in his
qualification powers and his
resurrection then he definitely deserves
to be where he is on this list but no
higher
going with kaname next up is komamora
former captain of the seventh division
komamura is a very unique Captain not
only in his wolf-like appearance but
also in his powers too yes he is of
course a master swordsman with expert
keto and shumpo knowledge but for me
it's his bunkai that really stands out
Above the Rest along with having clearly
one of the best names Coco Joe tengen
Mio is an absolute Beast of a Bankai in
short he replicates a huge body of
Living Armor that mirrors his moves this
thing has certainly been the difference
in a lot of his battles now it does have
a downside in the fact that whatever
damaged the armor giant takes it also
shares with coma Maura however the flip
side to this is that if komamora were to
heal himself mid-battle the armored
giant would also heal so this downside
also has its pros komamora is also the
first captain on this list that actually
has a few big W's to his name in key
battles against some pretty big
opponents his first noticeable fight was
against kempachi back in the Seoul
Society Arc where he managed to block
kempachi's strike with his arm and
helmet which led to the reveal of Koma
Mora's true appearance
we then saw him in action against Chao
Nang Poe barragon's largest fraxion
where his Bankai completely overpowered
him he managed to send paucero right
back down his throat before destroying
him with a single blow of his bunkai's
sword then there was of course the fight
that his character's story had been
leading up to which was against kaname
in the fake karakura Town Arc komamora's
bonkai completely shattered kaname's
left arm with only a single strike
however kaname did have the upper hand
thanks to his holification powers and
his resurrection but komamura and his
Sagi did come out with the win in this
one his last battle was against
bambietta where we got to see Coco Joe
tengen Mio dangai Joe which was where
his bonkai removed its armor
dramatically increasing its destructive
power as well as making it pretty much
invulnerable all to any physical harm
now this form is only possible if
komamora uses the humanization technique
where he sheds his Beast form and
returns to that of his human one however
this is at the cost of removing his own
heart pretty gnarly stuff and one insane
power boost with significant
consequences because of this kobamora is
without a doubt one of the strongest
captains and to this day one of my
favorites like I mentioned he is just so
unique and his powers are just an
absolute joy to watch
Rukia kuchki the captain of the 13th
division is up next we have seen a lot
of rookia over the series as the leading
lady of the show and as such have beared
witness to the power that she has and
developed over the course of the story
Rukia is a master of Keto a very
competent fighter and an expert with her
zompoc toe as zompoc toe that is said to
be the most beautiful in all of the Soul
Society she is an ice user similar to
heatsagaya though different in her use
of it her Bankai also considered the
most beautiful in all of the Soul
Society turns Rukia into a literal ice
queen who has the power to control the
temperature around her she can make
everything so cold to the point that it
is unable to move and even shatter
she has had some great battles over the
course of the series and taken a few big
W's with her along the way her first
major fight I would say was against the
Espada adeniero a battle that not only
showcased what she was capable of but
also one in which we saw emotional
growth we also got to see how tactical
she can be when she managed to expose
his true form before impaling him with
her sowed no shilaiuki Rukia is without
a doubt a strong character and her
Bankai is extremely impressive albeit
for the need to learn a little more
control as to not suffer any fatal
consequences once she has full Mastery
over that I am sure she will be much
higher on this list
next up is the commander of the Stealth
Force and second division Captain soy
phone soy phone is a master assassin and
an absolute master of her craft she is
very fast and can take down multiple
opponents in an instant before even
being seen herself we saw her shikai in
action against yorichi which was
extremely deadly especially in the hands
of someone as skilled as soy phone
Hershey Kai is a poison that will take
down her opponent if they are stabbed in
the same spot twice by Susan abachi in
that same battle we got to see another
very impressive ability in her Arsenal
which was that of her shenko this
combines hand-to-hand combat with keto
to deliver some extremely powerful blows
at the time of that battle she hadn't
completely mastered it but has
definitely developed it much further
since then now the in interesting thing
about soy phone and her style of combat
is the complete Stark difference in her
Bankai a different so bold that she
actually refrains from using it as it
damages her Pride as the commander of
the Stealth Force however her Bankai
also delivers a lot of damage to her
opponent we first saw it in her battle
against the Espada Baragon and it was
just absolutely insane it is basically a
huge rocket that hones onto its Target
completely destroying them on impact now
in that same fight against barragon we
also got to see her determination her
will and her ability to keep calm and
collected In the Heat of battle as she
lost her left arm but managed to
continue fighting against an extremely
strong opponent and most importantly she
came out of that battle alive soy phone
is certainly no joke and very worthy of
the titles that she holds and is only
second to one other who will appear
later on in this list
captain of the 12th Division and second
President of the Shinigami Research
Institute mayori kuratsuchi is up next
and while he isn't really known all that
well for his strength he is certainly a
master in other areas and I think you
know to be honest that might be an
understatement mayori is incredibly
smart as you would expect of the Soul
society's mad scientist his style of
combat is all about extensive research
into his opponent prior to engaging them
and then utilizing that knowledge in the
form of tactics faints and even ambushes
rather than an all-out brawl mayori
utilizes drugs and equipment to gain a
sneaky advantage over his opponent and
completely overwhelm them with his
Superior intellect this isn't to say
that mayori can't brawl but the Mana is
all about results that's the line of
work he is in and he certainly strives
in it we saw just how well he plans his
strategies out beforehand and his fight
against the Espada Zia laparo he had
researched him so well that he knew
exactly what moves he was going to pull
off and when he was going to do them
xyle Apollo used his Voodoo ability in
which he can destroy a person's organs
however mayori had planned for this by
implanting fake organs within himself
xyloporo also tried to take control of
mayori's Bankai but again he knew this
was coming and had made countermeasures
beforehand and then the finishing blow
was when xyle Apollo had recreated
himself within nemu's body but mayori
had already placed a few drugs within
her that had now fused with xyloporo
leaving mayori disappointed in his
adversary But ultimately this gave him
the win now we saw the use of his shikai
and how it complements his fighting
style as early as the soul Society Arc
against Ishida where the Venom of his
Ashi sogi jizo cuts off the brain
signals to the limb of where he has
stabbed his opponent his Bankai also
utilizes a deadly poison that affects
everyone apart from himself once this
poison is breathed in it instantly
starts to break down that person from
the inside out mayori is just an
absolute mad genius the lengths he goes
to in terms of preparation and his
modifications to both his Bankai and
himself to create foolproof strategies
easily make him one of the most
strongest and one of the most terrifying
captains in the go Tai 13.
the final visor on the list but easily
the strongest of the bunch and its
leader is up next Shinji hirako is the
captain of Squad 5 as he was over 100
years prior before being stripped of the
rank Shinji is certainly a very strong
Captain not only strong but wise to
match as he is definitely a man with a
lot of experience under his belt his
sheikhai ability is also a really tricky
one to come up against as it utilizes
the power of Illusion when the sword is
spun it creates a Mist that places its
victims into an optical illusion where
all of their movements are reversed not
only Direction but perception is
affected too as we saw in his face off
with Eisen the fake karakura Town Arc
where we saw that he had caught Eisen
totally off guard leaving him confused
and Shinji was even able to strike him
with his zampark toe obviously this
wasn't enough to take down Eisen as the
difference in their skill sets at this
time were just far too great but the
fact that he managed to do this at that
time really does showcase to us just how
impressive and Powerful Shinji is
Shinji azervised also has hollification
powers that will greatly enhance his
abilities that being his speed strength
endurance but as well as that his
holification gives Shinji the ability to
fire off a very powerful Shadow blast
Shinji can also maintain his Hollow mask
for five minutes at a time so easily the
strongest of the visor captains and very
deserving of his reinstation as Squad
5's Captain we have never seen his
Bankai we know he has the ability to use
it but not what it does if it's anything
like the ability his sheikhai possesses
then you bet Shinji could climb up a few
places higher on this list
Gene ichimaru was the former third
division Captain prior to his betrayal
of the sole Society alongside both
kaname tozin and sosuke Eisen Keen was
hailed as a child genius as he was
extremely proficient and graduated from
the Shinigami Academy in just a single
year not long after that he gained a
seated position this praise and high
expectancy for his talent was certainly
not wasted as Gene became a very strong
Shinigami Gene just has everything you
would expect of a powerful captain of
the goatai 13. he is strong has a
Mastery of his zompoc toe a keen
intellect as well as a large spiritual
pressure but where Gene really shines is
in his calm-headed nature and Mastery of
both manipulation and deception Gene
remains calm at all times and is rarely
ever taken back by his opponents move
sets and abilities he instead toys with
his opponents utilizing psychological
warfare weakening both their mind and
resolve in order to give him the
advantage his zompoc toe shinso is
amazing in its abilities where it can
extend or retract giving Gene the best
possible position when in combat now his
zompoc toe's deadliest ability is in its
Bankai with the ability named kurose
kamishini no Yari in which he can turn
his zompoc toe into a dust when it is
extending and retracting that will find
its way into his opponent's body and at
his command will break down that
person's cells from the inside
Keen played the game and waited for his
moment to make his move on Eisen using
kamashini no Yari to stop him and take
the hokiyoku Keen was successful but
only for a brief moment but he certainly
pulled off a huge move here gain was a
very strong Shinigami now I only wish we
got to see more of him and his abilities
in the series he was easily one of the
strongest and fastest long range
fighters in the go Tai 13 and his
bankai's true ability was one that
really gave geen a deserved high place
on this list
ishine Kurosaki was the former 10th
division captain and a very strong and
very dangerous Captain to come against
Gene was an absolute Powerhouse and had
it all enhanced strength and speed an
amazing amount of spiritual energy and a
zompoc toe that could stand up against
anyone the man just has an absolute
presence about him and when he is on the
battlefield he is an opponent not to be
taken lightly now with just the single
flick of a finger ashine managed to send
Eisen flying through a good few
buildings A Move that he calls only Deco
pin his zonpok too and its shikai came
with some pretty op abilities too we saw
him use engetsu's ability to deal a huge
amount of destructive power if he was to
spit his own blood onto the sword we
also saw him use an insanely powerful
getsuga ten show against Eisen that
split him straight down the middle now
ishin is definitely Rusty in the fights
we have cinnamon and that's due to the
fact that hasn't been a Shinigami in a
very long time as a former captain and
head of one of the five Noble houses we
know that he possessed a huge amount of
power like he is powerful now but back
then he was even stronger we also know
that he does have bunkai but because of
the strain that it puts on his body and
the fact that is Sheen can no longer
easily fix his spiritual energy we have
never seen him use it but we can only
imagine at just how insane his bonkai
would be and for me a full powered is
Sheen of the past would probably make it
into the top five but because of how he
is now he will remain just outside of
the top 10 but man what an amazing
Captain he is in terms of raw power
next up we are into the top 10 and we
have another child prodigy and the
youngest Shinigami to become a captain
of the go type 13. none other than
toshiro hisagaya captain of the 10th
division hisagaya is an excellent
captain and Commander he is probably the
captain we have seen in combat the most
and has an impressive set of wins under
his belt as a captain he's the Gaia of
course has all the tributes you'd expect
a captain to have but one of his
strongest is that of his Keen intellect
Instinct and intuition sometimes he can
be a bit ruthless in his way of thinking
but this is all due to his age and
experience compared to the other
captains as well as this we have seen
him lose himself to his emotions where
other captains would have remained calm
and collected nonetheless heatsagaya has
proved that he can get the job done on
many an occasion now being the youngest
ever captain in the go Thai 13
heatsagaya is also the youngest to
achieve Bankai his power is the
manipulation of both ice and water
something that he has demonstrated a
high level of Mastery at however even
though these skills and power are
displayed due to his age his bonkai
hasn't matured properly yet despite this
we have seen him use a large amount of
abilities in fact he may have the most
we have seen in the show to be honest
his most notable fights were against
Espada tier Harry Bel where he really
showed off the fact that his age and
experience wasn't a problem of course
not an easy battle in the slightest but
one that really did highlight what he is
capable of after the final battle
against Eisen heatsagaya spent 18 months
developing training and strengthening
his bunkai during the thousand year
blood War Ark here sagaya fought against
Gerard Valkyrie and we got to see the
results of said training that being
daiguran jorin Maru hisagaya is
definitely deserving of such a high
place on this list and again due to his
age we know that he is only going to
improve and get stronger so it'll be
interesting to see where he will
eventually end up in a weakest to
strongest list but for now he stands
very very proudly here
the number nine spot goes to the former
13th division Captain juiciro ukitake
ukitake is the image of a calm collected
Serenity but that appearance should not
fool you as this man is as deadly a
warrior as they come he is an absolute
master of Keto in fact his Mastery of it
has immensely enhanced all of his
abilities to a very impressive level we
saw just how impressive a swordsman he
was when he teamed up with shunsui to
take on none other than the Headmaster
Yamamoto himself now the battle ended in
a draw with Yamamoto surely coming out
as the Victor but he and shunsui earned
well respected and deserved praise from
their Master one of which being his
zompoc toe ukitake has the best defense
of any of the captains due to the
ability of his shikai this allows him to
split his
into two separate blades and absorb the
attack coming at him the power of their
attack travels through a rope connecting
the blades at their Hills where ukitake
will fire it right back at them with
much more power than the original attack
had
[Music]
such impressive move and one we saw him
use in the battle against the Espada
Stark now ukitake was unfortunately
plagued with a deadly illness so we
never really got to see him at his full
potential and with that we never saw
what the power of His bunkai was but
from what we did see of him we were all
very well aware at just how powerful a
captain he was again here's another case
where I could very well see him being
higher on the list if we knew what his
full potential was but let's face it top
10 is still a very impressive feat
next up we have the former captain of
the second division and commander of the
Stealth Force yorichi shihowing we spoke
earlier in the video that the current
captain of the second division and
commander of the Stealth Force soy phone
was only second to one other and that
one other is without a doubt yorichi she
is utterly amazing and the true master
of assassination she just has all the
attributes she'd expect of a person in
this role but what makes yorichi that
much more impressive is her flash step
it is that impressive that she holds the
title of flash goddess or Flash Master
she can move at Great distances in the
blink of an eye making it impossible for
her opponent to keep up she has mastered
the flash step to the point where it
appears that she is in multiple places
at once wiping out entire squads in a
matter of seconds just as soy phone has
the Shinko ability as does yorichi but
hers is far more advanced and more
importantly controlled we saw in her
battle against soy phone the difference
in its use and as the series has gone on
we have seen it evolve further with her
Thunder God battle form as well as her
Thunder beast battle form now yorichi
does have a zomp October but she rarely
ever uses it as she prefers to fight in
a hand-to-hand combat style she is
without a doubt one of the strongest
unarmed users in all of bleach so we can
understand her reasoning behind not
using her zonpok toe
seventh spot Goes To None other than
biogria kuchki he is the captain of the
sixth Division and the 28th head of the
kuchiki clan biochia is one of the
strongest captains in Bleach no question
about him in fact he was one of the
first captains we saw in the series and
a true indication at the immense power
that these captains have now one of the
things that stands out about biochia is
his incredible speed using the flash
step technique which was taught to him
by yorichi his favorite and a very very
devastating ability is called Sanka
where he moves at his opponent's back
directly attacking and sealing their
sequetsu and hakasui in two very rapid
and devastating strikes these strikes
cut off his victim's spiritual energy
flow now this was what he used on Ichigo
in the very early stages of the story
when biochi has character was introduced
to us
flash step aside biochia easily has one
of the most unique beauty beautiful and
truly terrifying zompoc toe in all of
bleach called
zenbonzakura it's shikai and bonkai
utilize tiny petals that cause
devastating slashes to his enemy it's an
utterly overwhelming technique that many
of his victims have fallen prey too now
move sets aside biochia is probably the
master of calm and calculated decisions
without any hesitation when he fought
against the espartas Amari biochia lost
control of his left leg due to the
asparta's power of being able to control
whatever it is his eyes gaze upon
without a second of hesitation biochia
cut the tendons of his left leg so it
was unable to be used against him it's
those kind of decisions that set him
apart from the rest and the fact that he
truly has the speed and power to back it
up making biochia one of the strongest
characters in the entire series
next up is the former fourth division
Captain retsu unahana she was one of the
eldest and most experienced go Thai 13
captains and was the best healer in all
of the Soul Society now she was pretty
much used or only ever seen as a Healer
in the show so to those who don't know
about unahana this placement will come
as a surprise and just to warn you again
spoilers here so it wasn't until the
Thousand-Year blood War Arc that we
truly got to see just how strong and
terrifying unahana really was so she was
to teach 11th division Captain kempachi
Zaraki zonjutsu in order to teach
kempachi how to become stronger the two
engaged in a battle to the death and we
find out a couple of things in this
fight so unahana was once the most
diabolical criminal in all of the Soul
Society
Yamamoto actually sought her out when he
was putting the goatai 13 together and
she became the first captain of the 11th
division as well as the first kempachi
during a mission she came across a boy
who attacked her on site and the two
went on to fight that boy was none other
than a young kempachi Zaraki during
their battle kempachi himself admitted
that it was the first time that he had
felt fear in a battle ever since their
first fight he wanted more as he loved
this feeling when fighting this speaks
volumes to how much of a strong opponent
unohana is if Kenpachi was to say this
now the fight between the two was truly
great and we really got to see this new
side to unohana as well as the
impressive power that she possessed one
of the great mysteries about unohana was
her bunkai unfortunately there isn't a
lot known about it as she was slain
before we could really see what it was
capable of we only know a few things
such as when her Bankai is released the
blade of her zompoc toe turns into a
thick dark red liquid that flows all
around her which many have theorized is
blood but there is no confirmation of
that the liquid of her Bankai is that of
a very strong acid strong enough to melt
an opponent to the very bone as we saw
with campachi other than that I think
there was still so too much more to her
than we ever saw but from what we did
see and find out about unahana she is
clearly very deserving of this spot on
the list
okay top five now and in fifth spot is
none other than the absolute brute force
that is kempachi Zaraki 11th division
Captain so where to start with Kenpachi
so the guy is just an absolute force and
a master of combat now when I say a
master of combat I really do mean Master
as he lives and breathes battle his
whole soul driving force is just battle
and become stronger so naturally one of
the things that comes with that
lifestyle is of course a ton of
experience now the other captains tend
to keep him at arm's length and I always
get those kind of Outsider Vibes when it
comes to him we know just how strong the
captains are but they have chosen words
such as Supernatural and immeasurable to
describe zaraki's power now going back
to his battle against unahana prior to
becoming a division captain him when he
was young she herself mentioned that
despite being the one left standing in
their fight she knew that he was
stronger and better suited to become
kempachi Kenpachi himself has always had
untapped potential and he had never
bothered to try and tap into it due to
the fact that he was scared that his
fights would be over far too quickly if
he were to try and tap into his true
power and potential as such his eye
patch seals his overflowing and intense
spiritual power just so that he can
indulge in his love of combat but he has
removed it in a couple of fights and man
none was it truly a sight to behold when
he did that the guy was next to
Unstoppable his Bankai also matches the
same sealed theme in which he will
transform into a Berserker demon when he
activates his bonkai however this is at
the cost of his own sense of reason
kampachi is just so incredibly powerful
and there are very few who can beat him
at his best which is why he takes the
fifth spot on this list
[Music]
taking the fourth spot is the man the
myth the legend that is kisuke urahara
kisuke was the former 12th division
captain and president of the Shinigami
Research Institute and man man is this
guy impressive
Lara is without a doubt arguably the
smartest character in the entire series
he is a master strategist and tactician
as well as a keen inventor that has gone
on to kanja some of the most unique and
Powerful items with the most devastating
being the hogioku now he isn't just
smarts as he is an expert in unarmed and
armed combat as well as being very very
experienced in keto use his Mastery of
Keto has not only allowed him to be able
to perform high level keto but he has
also created some high-level keto
himself which is a feat that speaks a
thousand words into the absolute
Brilliance of this man now it's his
zompoc toe particularly his Bankai that
ranks urahara as one of the strongest
captains or characters for that matter
in the entire Series so his bonkers
summons a crimson dressed giant woman
that gives kisuke the ability to tear
apart and re-stitch anything that he so
chooses things such as the terrain he is
fighting in you know he can increase the
strength of his muscles or even heal
himself from injury as we saw in his
fight against Askin no one is
invulnerable of course but urahara is
pretty close with the power of His
Bankai so it goes without saying not
only is urahara one of the most
important characters in this series but
also one of the strongest to which
easily gives him this fourth space in
the list that is getting you know pretty
insane with its Personnel at this point
the current commander of the gothai 13
and first division Captain shunsui
Kuroko is taking third place and man is
this guy impressive soon sweet is what
you would call the complete package yes
all the captains on this list share very
similar traits in terms of being masters
of swordsmanship
Etc but shun sway man he's just on a
completely different level across all
fields and it's because of this that it
is near impossible to defeat this man in
combat for he is just too powerful so
his zompoc toe is equally as impressive
as its personality is unlike any other
zampark time his zonpokto's personality
only comes to light in battle and will
only let shunsui fight at his full power
when it is in the mood for it and if you
wanted a clear example of just how
powerful he is then here we go so since
we took out the first ranked Espada
Stark only using his Sheik eye bruh not
only is this a flex on Shoon Suites
abilities but also a nod to the
terrifying power of His Bankai that
shinsui himself refuses to use unless
it's absolutely necessary reason being
is when he releases his Bankai and Aura
covers the area around shunsui this Aura
changes the perception of a person's
surrounding environment and causes those
trapped within its range to feel Despair
and sadness his Bankai causes mental
Despair and the effects of death and
because its effects affect everything
and everyone within its range shinsui
does not want to gamble with innocent or
Allied Forces who may be trapped within
its boundary now it's his bonkai
combined with just how strong he is when
he is not using it that confirms to us
that shunsui Kyoko is one of the
strongest Shinigami in all of existence
coming in at second is none other than
sosuke Eisen former fifth division
captain and a man that pretty much
attained god-like status after he
betrayed the soul Society Eisen has so
much spiritual energy the most in the
series can't even comprehend just how
powerful he really is
Eisen was pretty much an immortal being
who could take down any and everything
he wanted and you know what I I'm sure
even a deity wouldn't have been out of
his reach now when it comes to his time
as a captain Eisen was without a doubt
on his way to becoming one of the
strongest in the entire series he was
one of the strongest Swordsmen in the
gotai 13 and was also one of their
greatest military strategists and that's
the scary thing about Eisen his mind is
pretty much as powerful as his strength
is Eisen is a genius his his intellect
is just unmatched but he also uses his
genius for manipulation Eisen is
extremely cunning and has betrayed so
many that have fallen into the Trap of
trusting him and when it comes to his
power the best way to understand just
how strong he is is to look at the
battles that he has fought and won well
Eisen basically took on the entire go
tie 13 and the Wizards and came out of
it as the Victor if that wasn't enough
to convince you then look at the time
that he also went against the PowerHouse
Trio of ishinkurasaki yuruichi shihowin
and kisuke urahara and again came out on
top Eisen is just absolutely insane the
man is pretty much unbeatable if it
wasn't for of course Ichigo sacrificing
his spiritual powers to use mugetsu if
he hadn't have done this Eisen would
surely have gone on to have either
destroyed or ruled over the entire world
first place goes to the absolute Legend
and beast mode captain that is none
other than the former commander and
founder of the ghost High 13 and first
division Captain genre usai Yamamoto
Yamamoto is just Next Level power and
someone who you just have no hope of
besting in fact he served as the go Tai
13's Commander for over 1 000 years due
to the fact that there was just no other
Shinigami that was stronger than him
despite his old age he was a master of
everything and even wielded the oldest
sonpark toe a zampokto that was so
powerful that it was stronger than all
of the other zampokto in the soul
Society combined yes combined and his
sheikhai release Commander alone just
lets you know how much of a beast mode
Powerhouse Beefcake this guy is man I'm
talking all things in the universe turn
to ashes I mean come on you do not get
any more than that that that there is
the highest level nothing more can top
that you you don't go any higher than
that now speaking of his shikai and
bonkai the power they willed is almost
disgusting you know the Flames they emit
cut or burn everything out of existence
again if that doesn't sound super op to
you then I honestly don't know what else
does his Bankai also comes with some
nasty abilities with one of them being
able to summon the Fallen at his hand so
not only can he summon those he has
defeated but he can also choose who it
is that he summons meaning that this
Powerhouse can defeat whoever he wants
and then just summon them to fight
alongside him Yama please just stop
honestly you know I could should go on
for an eternity about how strong
Yamamoto is and why I am so apparently
in love with his power but just know
that there is no Captain that has any
hope of getting anywhere near this man's
power he is number one always has been
always will be
and that is it every Captain ranked from
weakest to strongest we certainly hope
that you enjoyed this ranking as it
really was a lot of fun to make so we
just want to say a quick thank you for
all of the support on the bleach content
on the channel thus far it's been an
absolute privilege to bring these videos
to you definitely make sure to let us
know you made it to the end of the video
by telling us in the comments if you
agreed with our ranking and how you
would rank the captains also just give
old man Yama some more love I I do I
don't think I did enough I don't now if
you enjoyed this video and you'd like to
see more bleach videos on the channel
make sure to let us know by Smashing
that like button get Suga ten show style
if you haven't make this the video you
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future anime abroad videos remember
you can also follow us on Twitter and
Instagram at anime Oprah thanks again
and we honestly really can't wait to see
you in the next video till next time
friends